[Musik]
wie definieren sie terrorismus physik-
rio 2 gibt es eigentlich aus chicago
einst der allerdings überhaupt keinen
grund
und zita 1 2 1 aus names voller aus dem
jahr 2015 von dennis burke mit josh
brolin und weniger del toro
die beiden sind auch wieder dabei der
große unterschied und das ist vielleicht
auch der grund warum man sagen kann die
kerio 2 wäre nicht unbedingt nötig
gewesen ist dass emily blunt die im
ersten teil die hauptrolle eigentlich
spielte nicht mehr dabei dass wir haben
hier also eine die fortsetzung oder
einen zweiten film mit gewissermaßen
demselben team ohne die seele vom ganzen
und das ist sehr bedauerlich
es gibt unendlich viele in die luft es
gibt sehr viele tote ist ist teilweise
unerträglich brutal was dort passiert
oder auch über für mich zumindest über
die grenze hinaus brutal wenn man das
aber alles mal so ein bisschen zur seite
schiebt findet man trotzdem noch etwas
wird dass der film sich lohnt zu gucken
vielen leuten sitzt im hinteren wagen
ich denke auch leute die secardeo
gesehen gehen vielleicht in diesen film
weil sie hoffen etwas von der qualität
des ersten wieder zu sehen und da kann
man vielleicht zweierlei seien zum einen
sind die darsteller alle toll also die
sind wirklich so war es sozusagen die
können alle muss man natürlich auch
sagen dass berlin kann diese rolle
innehaben schlaf spielen und bin ich der
letzte eigentlich auch das mädchen ist
mit überraschung und großartig ist im
musik hilft uns einen krieg anzufangen
letztlich ist es so sieht cabrio war ein
toller film und jetzt geht jemand anders
hin und versucht dann nochwas
herauszupressen
es ist gar keine einzige neue idee wenn
es erst einen sieg nur noch mal eintritt
der besuch einer weiteren ausbeutung der
grundidee nämlich eine geschichte in der
es eben musikalien noch um
drogenkartelle geht hier geht es gar
nicht auch eigentlich gar nicht mehr um
drogenkartelle sondern es fängt an mit
der frage werden über die mexikanische
grenze mexikanische texanische grenze
islamistische körpers beschloss also das
heißt diese ganze verbindung zu den
mexikanischen kartellen verläuft dann
irgendwie im sande große also meine
seitens großer flop fehler auch in dem
drehbuch
was erstaunlich ist weil der schein
einen wirklichen toller drehbuchautor
ist die ja auch helen drei wörter
geschrieben hat und seinen eigenen
winterberg seinen eigenen film auch
schon gemacht hat und daher möglich
immer sehr viel konzentrierter
gearbeitet hat also ein bisschen habe
ich das gefühl hier sollte doch noch ein
bisschen geld gemolken werden aus einem
gebiet aus einer ursprüngliche idee die
in dem ersten film doch deutlich wasser
deutlich konzeptuelle durchgearbeitet
worden werden
wir wollen dass sich die fäden körper
du musst sie beseitigen das kann ich
nicht
was meinst du damit aber nicht
viel glück